あああああ
乳母のは革新んだよゆるーくスポーツでもしましょうかと思ったんですけども我々も
運動不足なので過度な運動すると死んでしまうマシな方でね各な運動してしまうと死ん
じゃうのでちょっとこうなんか一ラクにできるスポーツはないかと思ったんですけど
めちゃスポーツテットってやりましたね
ええええええええええ
すぽテストの中で反応守るだけあバリ風に見えた桜
スポーツ s の中で高など気軽に行けるスポーツ言ったらなんでしょ
いやーもうそれはシャトルラン取るフォール投げを公開してみようと思います巻尺とが
結構ガチで発露と思っててあんなゴールだけでちょっと実際に我々の腕の通達を図ろう
と思います浸からないように見れて見えて
つかないように見れて多分生まれた強いんで吠え考えてたら腕だ負荷に使う言われと
多分で腕の疲れに合う心があると思うんで
シンプルにちょっと我々のハンドこの記録が測ってみようと思います
干支高校1年生のダンスの平均記録が25.7m 高校になって男子が27名と高校3
年生がピークで27m
上するに多分27メートル越えたら男とした立派なんじゃねえかという感じだし
ブロックし選手のスポーツテストは高校時代65m ですよね美味しいでしょ
もうメーター超えざーからね大学1年
生の男子平均が26大学にいないせいか26
ちょっと役立つ大学3年生からは記録がないらしい分
一応参考に女子は女子はずっと14が15m
助手は中45メートルくらいが平均です女子高生女子大生くらいですなので我々は1羽
ゼロからスタートす27m はだいたいですね
遠くでゼロからはず
しまって多分あそこら辺が27m あそこが大事な平均でございます
えっ
ぜひで行った部屋まず正木いきましょう頼んだぞ
それができ目標は
ねええええ
4日おっしゃっ平均レベルにいくんここがね16なぁ
僕で大事に行けるじゃ行き
えっ
me
ak こういったんじゃないここで食後だからああ
結果でましたって言われましたケルナーさんです
そこですはい結果わー22.7m よああいやあああっ
だけバカじゃん運動しないからね反省点としては多分コレ
いません
ここが27
4ではどうぞ
いやぁああああああ
なるほどなったら合っにここだけですもう一つ果たしてねっ
記録は大
ってもあっても
ぐらいだと白くても運2さん
行けましたそこで作りました
記録だ
26.7m ああああっいやーでも平均平均
平均でやっぱ税金兵器へ出るいやよくやってるけどさ
ああああああ
すぐ分かりやすい分かりますへ
オスねー
なうですね
速報でそこですけどネスっていうか
5.7ん
何とも言えねぇ普通のスポーツテストだしてに買い得
3つも行けずになりましょうって次で受かったこの議論があってくるだけ本気でいき
たいとおもいます
ああああああ
いいいいいい
方も方法
いっ
結果長さん
そこで好きです
おっけか
22.7m カーンぞ ok
ういいえる
ん
大阪です
結果ああ
29.1さぁさぁ
うざいうざいうざいうざいうざい受けられないということで
もう今日はウェア
3ずに
a
そんな弱ったかな俺夢30m ぐらいですねとか32
やばい
そうか方でさーこアドレス結果が出ました結果はいっ
30店の客あああっっっ
me
nao
バッハ
色々という中ば腕は使うのでぜひ流通バーの皆さんハンドボールは消してみてはいかが
でしょうか
じゃあ